rock stars Grand Theft Auto series  brings in a lot of money that shouldn't  surprise anyone but a former rock star  executive suing publisher take-two  interactive that's something you don't  see every day and that's exactly what  Leslie Benzies the former head of  Rockstar North is doing Benzies left  rockstar north at the start of this year  after a 17 month sabbatical according to  his lawyer Christopher bakes benzies  discovered on this sabbatical that the  developer and publisher were conspiring  to force him out of the company and his  royalty payments the lawsuit claims he's  owed over a hundred and fifty million  dollars these sorts of stories are very  complicated and as such will continue to  follow the story as it develops there  are plenty of legal teams New York laws  and court appeals to wrap our heads  around but you can read all about the  latest developments on gamespot and for  all the Grand Theft Auto news you need  you already in the right place